Matt do you actually have to watch a  WNBA game or can you hang out at the  concession stands and walk around the  arena when you're at the WNBA game do  WWE NBA games even have concession  stands I don't mean that as a joke do  they actually sell like merchandise and  and food is it just some kid with a  lemonade stand selling lemonade and a  plastic cup for 25 cents but whatever it  is no I think I have to sit and actually  watch the game nobody's ever watched the  entire WNBA game not one single person  this is a scientific fact not one single  person in the world has ever actually  watched an entire WWE NBA game so I am  going to be that first person and we'll  find out maybe I'll enjoy it maybe I'll  get into it that would be a twist ending  that nobody would see coming